So let's begin now.
First of all,
I'm assuming all of you have some idea
what special relativity meet that are two
theories of relativity. One, his special
theory and one is a general theory.
The general theory is something we
won't do it. Any detail. The specialty,
it is something we will
do in reasonable detail.
So it got to begin by asking
some of you what is your
present understanding of what the
subject is all about? Yes sir.
He heel cap. What do you think? It's about
reference system.
Okay. It's about relative
speed and to reference system.
I'll come to you then I'll come to you.
Yes.
The laws of physics in any reference range
initially and constantly.
Okay. I will take a last row there. Yes.
Okay,
so what I've heard so far is that the
laws of physics are the same for two
people who are both inertial frames of
reference and the velocity of light is a
constant,
right?
That's certainly the way we understand,
especially the relativity theory,
but it's a very old one. It's been
going on long before I enshrined came.
There is a theory of relativity at the
time of Newton and that's where I want to
begin. The relativity is not a
new idea at all. It's an old one
and the whole idea can be illustrated
in this way and it will agree with your
own experience.
So the standard technique for all of
relativity is to get these high speed
trains. I'm going to have
our own high speed train.
There's the top view of the train and
like in everything I do will get away with
the lowest number of dimensions,
which happens to be,
there's one special dimension
and of course that is time.
So the train is moving along the x axis.
You are in this strain,
you board the train and
all the blinds are closed
because you're not,
you don't want to look outside.
Well that's not because you're traveling
through some parts of New Jersey.
You don't want to look outside.
They don't want to look outside
for this particular experiment.
Get into the train.
You settled down and you
explore the world around you.
You pour yourself a drink,
you play pool,
you juggled some ping pong balls,
tennis balls,
and you have a certain
awareness of what's happening,
namely your understanding of the
mechanical world. And then you go to sleep
when you're sleeping.
Some unseen hand gives to this strain.
A large velocity,
200 miles an hour.
Question is when you wake up,
can you tell if you're moving or not?
That's the whole question.
Will Lewis Speed,
whatever they gave you,
200 miles per hour will do anything to
you in this strain that'll betrayed that
velocity. So when you wake up,
when you say I'm moving or not,
now you might say,
I'm not moving because I am an Amtrak
and I know this strain is not going
anywhere. That kind of
sociological reasons. By the way,
there are many of them you cannot invoke.
You can only say I haven't.
The strain is anything different.
And the claim is that
nothing would be different.
You just will knock know you're moving.
Now,
if the train picks up speed or slows down,
you will know right away.
If it picks up speed dot accelerates
you and find yourself pushed against the
back of the seat of the driver,
slams on the break,
he will slam in the front
of the seat in front of you.
No one is saying that when the motion
is accelerated, you will not know.
Accelerated motion can be detected
close strain without looking outside.
Question is uniform velocity.
No matter how high can that be perceived,
can that be detected?
So at the time of Galileo
and Newton, everybody agreed
that you cannot detect it.
Remember that if you started out
and Newton's laws work for you,
you're calling an inertial observer
one of the laws. You want this.
If you leave something,
you should stay where it is one.
When the train is accelerating,
that won't be true.
You leave things on the floor when it's
accelerating things from slide backwards.
So with no apparent force acting on it,
things will begin to accelerate.
That's a non inertial frame.
We're not interested in that.
You started out as a observer for whom?
The Laws of Newton work,
law of inertia works,
FSE called [inaudible].
Then you go to sleep and you wake up.
So when I said everything looks the same,
I really meant that the laws of Newton
continue to be the same because if the
laws of Newton are the same,
everything will look the same.
That's what it means to say
everything looks the same.
I would expectations and what
happens when I throw it up,
but what happens when two
billiard balls collide?
Everything is connected
to the loss of newt.
So the claim is a loss of Newton who
will be unchanged when this velocities
added onto you.
Now we should be clear about one thing.
If there is a train next
to you in the beginning,
let me just put it on this
side for convenience and
you got in and you bought it
this train, but you looked at
this rain, it was not moving.
If you lift the blind and look through,
you'll see the other train and that's
another passenger in the other train and
you look at each other,
you're not moving
when you wake up after this brief nap.
You find when you look outside,
the other train is moving
at 200 miles an hour.
The question is can you tell if it's
you who's responsible for this relative
motion?
It may be nothing happened to you and the
other train is moving the opposite way
and the claim of relativity is
that you really cannot tell.
You can tell that this motion between
the two trains that wasn't there before.
That's very clear if you look outside,
but there is no way to tell what
actually happened when you were sleeping.
Whether you are given the velocity of
200 to the right or the other train was
given over last year, 200 to the left
or maybe a combination of the two.
You just cannot tell.
That's the word relative.
So far I didn't tell you
if you have only one train,
what I told you earlier is that uniform
velocity does not leave an imprint on
anything you can measure.
If you look outside,
of course you can see the
motion of the other train,
but you still cannot tell who is moving.
You cannot distinguish between different
possibilities. So you are every,
you have every right to insist that you
are not moving and the other train is
moving the opposite way.
Once again,
you can make this argument only
for uniform relative motion.
If your train is accelerating.
Now I'm saying it as if it's
an absolute thing and it is,
you cannot say I'm not accelerating the
other trainers accelerating the other
direction.
You cannot say that because you're the
one who was barfing up and throwing up
and slamming your head on the wall.
Nothing's happened. The other person,
you cannot say, uh, I'm still in the same
frame. You are going the opposite way.
If you're going the opposite way,
why am I throwing up so or if
a rocket rockets taking off,
you know, the g forces are
enormous. Many times your weight.
It's the astronauts who are going
through the discomfort at that time.
They cannot say we are addressed and
everyone's going the opposite way because
no one else is in danger.
But you are.
So accelerated motion will
produce effects. You cannot
talk your way out of that.
But uniform velocity will
produce no effects on, you know,
effects on the other person.
You can detect relative motion,
but you cannot in any sense main thing
that you are moving and he's not or he's
moving new or not. You can say I am
addressed things at the same as before.
The train is moving the opposite way.
Now if you go in the Amtrak and you look
outside and you don't see another train
but you see the landscape,
you see trees and cows and everything
going at 200 miles an hour in the opposite
direction,
you have some reason to believe that
probably the ground is not moving and
you're moving.
But that just based on what I called
earlier to some sociological factors,
in other words,
it's completely possible to devise an
experiment in which somebody puts the
whole landscape on wheels. And when
you go to sleep, the landscape,
cows and trees that are made to move
the opposite way, not very likely.
But that's because we know in practice,
no one's going to bother to do that just
to fool you. But if that did happen,
you won't know the difference.
So the reason we ruled that out as being
or some extraneous things not connected
to the laws of physics.
That's why we don't like to take open
the window and look at the landscape
because then we have a bias.
Open the window,
look at another train
and you just want to know
that does the principle of relativity,
that uniform motion between two observers,
[inaudible] is relative. Each one can
insist that he or she is not moving.
The other person is the one who is moving.
Of course.
Now if the two, in reality, if
the two trains were addressed,
let's imagine my train got accelerated
so during the time it goes accelerator I
would know,
but if I was sleeping at that time,
I don't know end when I wake
up at the acceleration is gone.
The velocity is constant.
That's when I say I just cannot tell.
All right now let's
show once and for all that the loss of
Newton, I'm not going to be modified.
So you find the loss of Newton
before you go to sleep. You wake up,
you find them again,
you won't get the same laws.
That's the claim and I hope you understand
that all the mechanical things you
see in the world around you
just come from ethical semi.
We have seen a project times and
collision or billiard balls and rockets.
They're all Newtonian mechanics,
so to say that things will look the same
is to say the loss of Newton that you
will, that use before and after
waking up will be the same.
So let's show that when you show that
you're really done with it once and for
all.
So let's do the following [inaudible]
the x axis and here is my frame of
reference. This is my exaxis.
Next column is the origin.
The frame was the negative
and positive x values.
Pick some object sitting at the point x.
Now we are going to first
define the notion of an event
and events is something that happens
at a certain place at a certain time.
That's called an event.
Yeah.
For example, if there's a little cracker
going off somewhere at some time,
some time the x is where it had
happened and the t is when it happened.
So this is space time.
Once again,
space time does not require
Einstein coming in at all.
We have known for thousands of years.
If you want to set up a
meeting with somebody,
you got to say where and you've got to
say when and things do happen in space
time. The fact that you need x and t Odey
for living in three spatial dimensions,
fact that they need x, Y,
Z, and T. It's not new.
That is not that
evolution that am created.
The fact that you need for coordinates,
labeling event is nothing new.
What he did that is new.
It will be clear later
so everyone understand
what an event means. Okay.
You went to something that happens and
to say exactly where and when it happened
in our world that one dimension, we'll
give it an accident. We'll give it a tea.
No, that's me and I'm going
to give my frame of reference.
The name s turns out s this
not just based on my name.
This is canonical name for two observers.
One is called less and one is called s
prime, so s prime. Let's say it's you.
So your frame of reference is going to
be taken to be sliding relative to mine.
So I don't know how to draw this.
And let's draw a y axis here.
We don't really deal with
the white coordinate, but
just to give you a feeling,
uh, this is my y axis that's
makes acts as this my origin.
Why is not going to play a big
role? No, you are sliding this way.
Put that right in your speed
and velocity is always denoted by you.
So some number of meters per second,
you're zooming to the right at some speed.
You,
so you imagine now you
got to going past me some.
I'm instant. I'm sitting here
at the audit in of coordinates,
you cross me and then little
later you are somewhere there.
So that's your white prime is that's
your origin and the same event you see it
has a coordinate x prime.
We already did.
So that when you're zoomed past me,
you set your clock to zero.
And I set my clock to zero when you
wanted to set the clock to see it as
completely arbitrary. So we will decide
right when you pass me, I'm am the audit.
You know my coordinates. You are the
artist in New York coordinates, right?
When you pass me,
we'll click our stopwatches and
we will set the time to zero.
Yeah,
so here's an event you and I crossed.
What are the coordinates for that event?
According to me,
that event occurred at x equals zero
and the claim was chosen to be zero
according to you.
Your origin was also on top of my audit
and so explained was zero and the time
is just the time. Everybody has a
single time. That time was called zero.
That is one event.
We Amanda coordinated the demand
zero zero for both you and me.
It is zero in space because
my origin cross your origin.
That crossing took place at my origin.
That's where my ex is.
Zero took place at your origin.
That's what you're explaining is you know,
and the common time he chose
to be zero by convention.
Yeah.
Then we want a second event.
So let's say the second event is
some firecracker going off here.
Here's something I should explain that
I've used to forget in the previous years.
When I say I am moving,
I imagine I am part of a huge team
of people who are all moving with me.
So I got agents all over the x
axis who are my eyes and ears.
They're looking out for me.
So even though I am here,
just a firecracker exploding here,
my guys will tell me,
and you are carrying your own agents.
Let's say at every point x you have a
reporter x equal to one, two, three, four.
There are people sitting and watching.
So when I say my,
when I say I see something I really
mean me and my buddies all traveling the
same train at the same speed, all over
space, taking notes on what's happening.
We will pull out information later, but
we know this explosion took place here.
I would simplify it by saying I know an
explanation and exploit explosion took
place here at location x at time t
so this is our crossing this event.
It's been be crossed then
that is a firecracker
but firecracker,
I have to give some events.
I said took place at location x at time.
T
what did you say? You measured
the distance from your origin.
You call it [inaudible]. The time is
still tea. In Newtonian mechanics,
the time is just the time.
How many seconds are past?
It's the same for everybody.
The question is what is
the relation between x,
prime and x?
That's what we want to think about,
so you guys should think before it.
Write down the answer.
What's the relation of x prime two x?
Well,
this event took place at time t so I
know that your origin is to the right by
and I'm on your time,
Steve.
Okay,
so the distance from your
origin for this event,
I maintain this x price is x minus ut.
Again, I want all of you to follow
everything. These are all simple notions.
Would origins coincided.
Ub Zero time for the event occurs at time.
T therefore know in a sense
you're rushing towards the event,
you've gone a distance. Ut therefore
the distance from your origins,
that event will be less than
mine by this amount. Ut.
This is the law of transformation of
coordinates in Newtonian mechanics.
If you haven't event, which occurs
at the, if you want formally,
you can define a time t prime
for the prime, the Observer.
It goes without saying that
t prime and t are the same.
There is no notion of time
for me and time for you.
That's universal time and you're
20 mechanics that are just runs.
We can call something a
zero once we have agreed,
if you say you and I met at [inaudible]
and explosion explosion took place,
five seconds after that we're meeting,
it's going to be five seconds after
meeting for me and it's going to be five
seconds after the meeting for you.
The time difference between two events,
it's the same for all people. This is
called the Galilean transformation.
Okay.
What are the consequences of
Galilean transformation? Well,
let's look at the fact that
x prime is x mine as ut.
Yeah.
You remember everything
is varying with time,
so x prime is a function of time
and x is the function of time.
If you're watching a moving party,
suppose this firecracker is not just
one event, but it's a moving object.
Let's give the object some speed.
It's moving to the right.
Then the velocity according to me,
I'm going to call V as Dxdt
is the velocity.
Let's just call it the bullet.
Okay.
According to s then w is a standard name
is the velocity of the bullet according
to as prime.
So what I've done is I first took one
event and I gave it some coordinates and I
told you how to transform the coordinate
from one person to the other person,
but now take that point x
not to be a fixed location,
but a moving object so that as a
function of time that body's moving.
Then it's velocity at any time.
Is the prime DT according to you.
That is the Dx d t according to me
minus the did ever do a bis just you.
Does that make sense?
They should agree with common sense.
For example, did that bullet's going
at 600 miles per hour to the right?
That is 600 for me
and you are going to the right in
your train or 200 miles per hour.
You should measure the bullet speed to
be reduced by 200 and you should get 400
that's all it means.
The two people will disagree on the
velocity of the bullet because they are
moving relative to each other.
This is the way you will add velocities.
Okay,
well let's look at the acceleration.
Dwd t is going to be Dvdt minus
zero because you as a constant,
that means you and I agree on
the acceleration of the body.
We disagree on where it is. We disagree
on how fast the bullets moving,
but we agree on the acceleration,
the body,
because all I've done this at a
constant velocity to everything you see.
Therefore,
if according to the velocity of the
body is not changing according to me,
the velocity of the body's not changing
because we bought the constant I added
will drop out of the difference
or the body as an acceleration.
We'll both get the same
answer for the acceleration.
So that is the common acceleration.
A So if you like a prime is the same as a
so the acceleration of bodies doesn't
change when you go from one frame of
reference and other one
going at a constant speed.
All right,
so let's look at ethicals Ama,
which is m d two x over DT square
is equal to some force on the body
and you look at the body and you
say need to extreme over dts.
Where is the force on your body?
First I want to convince you,
we wanted to see that the left hand side,
so at equal because the
acceleration is the same.
Then I want to convince you the right hand
side, so we're also going to be equal.
I can take many examples,
but eventually you will get the point.
Let us not consider one body,
but let's consider two bodies.
Two bodies are feeling a certain
force you to say gravitation
and gravitation is of course
a forest in three dimension.
But let's write the force
in just one dimension.
And let's say the force of gravity is
equal to one over x one minus six to four,
some one,
two,
two and the force on to you do one will
be minus of one over x one minus six
too.
Okay,
did he enforces that Arbonne?
There's separation in three dimensions,
but this is a fictitious force, I want
to call it gravity. It is any forced,
it depends on the coordinates
of the two particles.
So I will say m one the two x one
over d t square is one over x,
one minus x to
and m to do two x two over d t square
this minus one over x one minus.
I have forgotten constantly g and m one
and m two they don't matter for this
purpose.
So he hit our two bodies,
they feel a force for each other and I've
discovered what the forces is one over
x one minus X to,
I don't care if it one over x one minus
x two or x one minus x to the square.
That's not important.
What's important is it depends on x one
minus x to you come along and you study
the same two masses.
What will you say is happening?
You will say m one the two x one prime
over d t square is equal to one over x
one prime minus x two prime.
Maybe I will. Let me, I'm sorry.
Let me do it a little better.
I can tell you what you will see
given this is what I see.
I can tell you what you will see.
Let's do that in our head.
We know that the acceleration
is the same for any mass,
so I'm going to write this thing as
m of the x one prime over d this way.
In other words,
the acceleration according to me is the
same as the activation of according to
you.
Then I'm also going to write the right
hand side is x one prime minus x 2.0 do
you understand that if there
are two bodies feeling of force,
if you see it from a moving train,
the distance between the two bodies,
it's the same for you and me
because x one prime is x minus
ut x two primus x two minus ut.
Take the difference. The difference
between the location of the particular,
it's the same for you and me acceleration,
the same mass as
postulated to be the same.
So I know that you will get
the same law that I get.
You will get f equals a your
activation with the same as mine.
The force you attribute between the
two bodies and also be the same.
That is why I know that you will also
did use the same Newtonian laws that I
will.
Yeah.
You can also see it differently.
Uh, if I woke up from my nap and I am now
in the moving train and I examined the
world around me, I'm going to
get the same ethic. Was Amy
because they're seen by
a person on the ground.
The master's will be f equals m
a I am in this moving train. No,
but I have the same acceleration for
each mass and I have the same force.
If you want,
I'll complete the second equation to the
two x two prime over DT square will be
minus one over x one prime
minister can still cry
like this is a little difficult.
We should talk about this.
I'm telling you that if I did use
ethic was m a at the f depends on the
separation between the particles then I
am sure that you will find the same loss
of motion because the acceleration is the
same that I get because we have seen a
primus same as hay and the force will
also be the same because the force defense
on the separation between particles
and that doesn't depend on,
that doesn't depend on which train
unit or it's not affected by adding a
constant velocity to the frame
of reference. So if you like,
this is the way you prove in Newtonian
mechanics, that principle of relativity.
So not only is it something you
observed by going on trains and whatnot,
you can actually show that this is
the reason everything looks the same.
In other words,
if the train was at rest in the platform,
and you and I were comparing notes and
we both find f equals m a I go to sleep
and I'm waking up in the train
going at a constant speed.
If you can look through the window and
look at the objects in my train, you will,
you will say they will be f equals Amy
because nothing has happened to you.
But you will predict. I will
also say f equals, I mean,
because if you see an acceleration,
I will see the same acceleration.
If you see a distance between
two masters to be one meter,
I also think it's one meter. If the force
is one over the square of the distance.
We agree on the force, we agree on the
acceleration, will agree on everything.
And once you prove an
f equals m a is valid,
it follows that every mechanical
phenomenon will behave the same way.
That's the reason things
behaving the same way.
Yep.
Pardon me?
You mean if the room failed
in the other frame? Yeah.
Suppose hypothetically that happened,
then it would mean that when
you wake up in the train you,
we'll look at the world around you.
It will look different
because f is no longer a ma.
You will conclude when I went to sleep,
it was f equals, I may, when I got up,
F is not equal to Ama.
The train is moving.
So you will have to conclude that uniform
velocity makes detectable changes.
And if you look outside the train to
the other train or the train's going
backwards, you cannot no longer
say you are going the other way.
I'm not moving. Because the
other person will say, Hey,
I calls, I may works for me.
It doesn't work for you.
So you're the guy who's moving.
So you've lost the equal status with
other inertial observers because those for
whom f equals I may work,
we'll say they are not moving
and for you it doesn't work.
So you will have to consider your movie.
So uniform velocity,
if it makes perceptible changes,
can no longer be considered as relative.
Absolute.
And if you and I find each other moving,
that may be a real sense in which I am
addressing your moving because for me,
ethical, it works for you.
It doesn't, well, that's not
what happens in real life.
You find that works for both.
Then we say either of us can maintain.
We're not moving,
so now you've got a fast
forward to about 300 years.
This goes on. No problem. With
this principle of relativity.
In 300 years later,
people have discovered
electricity and magnetism,
electromagnetism and electromagnetic
waves with the identify as light and then
it was discovered that what you and I
call light is just electric and magnetic
fields traveling in space.
You don't have to know what electric
and magnetic fields are right now.
There are some measurable
phenomenon there.
Lake waves and the waves had a certain
velocity that Maxwell calculated that
velocity is this famous number three
times 10 to the eighth meters per second,
and the question was for who is this?
The velocity.
Then if for example,
you can do a calculation of waves on a
string or something we'll be able to do
in our course,
the waves on the string will be some
answer that depends on the tension on the
string and the mass density of the string.
And that's the velocity as seen by a
person for whom the string is at rest
artifact. Calculate the waves of sound
in this room, right? Talk to you.
You hear Miele slightly later the time
it takes to travel as the velocity of
sound in this room
that is calculated with respect to the
air in this room because the waves travel
in the air.
In fact,
the fact that all of us are sitting
on the planet but itself is moving at
whatever,
1100 miles per second doesn't matter
because the ad is being carried along.
So even if the earth campus,
I'm in the hall,
as far as the velocity of sound
in this room is concerned,
it won't matter because we
caddying the medium with us.
So people wanted to know
what does the medium,
which caddies the waves of light,
electromagnetic waves.
First of all,
the medium is everywhere because
then how do we know it's everywhere,
but they tell me,
yes, right? It travels
through the vacuum of space.
We can see the sun, we can see the stars,
so we know the medium is everywhere.
Then you can sort of ask how dense is
the medium. It turns out that denser,
the medium more rapidly signals travel
in most of the things that we know.
For example, when we look
at waves and sound, I'd,
when we look at the sound waves in a
solid or an iron, you'll find different,
very dense material velocity is very high.
So this medium, which is called
Ethan, would have to be very,
very dense to support waves
of this incredible velocity.
But then planners are moving through
this medium for years and years and years
and not slowing down.
It's a very peculiar media,
but it has to be everywhere.
So we are all immersed in this medium
because we're able to send light signals
to different parts of the universe.
And the question is,
how fast is the earth moving
relative to this medium?
Do you understand this medium?
Is all pervasive.
We know that we can see the stars,
so it's going all the way up to the stars
and beyond and we are immersed in this
and we are drifting around in space.
What is our speed relative to the media?
That's a question that was asked about
the find the spirit alert to the medium.
You calculate the velocity in
the medium by Maxwell's theory,
so here's the medium in which
waves travel at a certain speed.
This is planet earth going around the sun.
At some instant you will have a
certain velocity with respect to either
and therefore the velocity of light as
seen by you will be modified from C to c
minus V
in particular.
Suppose the waves are traveling
to the right in ether,
and let me try it this way.
The earth is going at this instant.
At a speed V we expect
the speed to VC minus v
because part of the speed is neutralized
because you're going along with the
waves.
You will see a slower velocity.
So Mr Michelson and his assistant morally,
they did the experiment
and they got the answer equally with this,
what does that mean?
What does that mean?
If you go yes,
no, no, but you cannot jump to that
right now. If you are following
Newtonian physics, you're expectation
is it should be c minus B. Yes.
Yup.
It means that there is no,
well, that's not so fast, but it
certainly means the following,
but that's the simple answer then that.
Yes.
[inaudible]
with what speed?
Zero.
Zero because you don't have to look,
you guys had already to
overthrow everything because
you know the answer, right?
Well,
you got to put yourself in the place of
somebody in early 1900 there's no reason
to overthrow anything. The answer
this, you are going at a speed zero.
Of course you realize it's incredibly
fortunate that on the one day Michelson
wants to do the experiment.
We happened to be addressed
with respect to the ether. Fine,
but we know that luck is not going to
last forever because you're going around
the sun
on a particular day.
Maybe that velocity was such
that on that day the earth was,
it rest with the specter of the ether is
clear the six months later when you're
going the other direction,
you cannot also be addressed
with respect to the ether.
But that's what you find
when you do the experiment.
You find every day get the same answer.
Any jolly will know you are not addressed.
You're moving around the sun for sure.
Yep.
Yeah.
So people try other solutions,
but it's simply a fact that when you
move one way or six months later,
the opposite way, you get
the same answers. See,
so one possibility is,
uh,
you don't want to look, don't be ready
to do revolutions. You try to avoid it.
So one answer this,
look at the speed of sound.
You and I talked to each other
then and we talked to each other.
Six months from now,
you get the same speed of sound.
Speed of sound is published textbooks,
right? 700 and something miles per hour.
How come that doesn't
change from day to day?
Anybody here this site?
Tell me why the speed of sound
doesn't change from day to day,
even though we're moving.
No one here can.
Yes.
Uh, no. We are moving
even six months from now.
We get the same speed of sound in
this room, but I talked to you.
Does it matter what time
of year it is? Yes. Yeah.
We had cadding air.
As the earth moves through space,
it carries the air with you and the speed
of the waivers is with respect to the
medium.
If you can caddy the medium with you,
then it doesn't matter how fast
you're moving. So they tried that.
They tried to argue that the earth carries
ether with it the way it caddies ed
with them,
then it's not an accident.
You're addressed with respect to the
ether because you're taking it with you,
but it's very easy to show by looking at
distant stars that you cannot be doing
that. I don't have time to
tell you why that is true.
Yeah,
so you cannot take the ether with you.
You cannot leave it behind.
That's the impasse people with it.
So it's as if that is a car that's
going to the writer at a certain speed.
See, you moved to the writers
some speed, maybe see over to,
I expect you to get a speed c over
to, but you keep getting, see,
you go at three 40 the velocity of light,
you still get the velocity of light that
is very contrary to what we believe.
In fact, that's in violent
opposition to this law here.
If this V we're not a bullet,
but a light beam,
suppose for me it's traveling at a speed
c and you are traveling to the right
and speed you,
you should get c minus you.
That's an inevitable consequence of
Newtonian physics and you don't get that.
Okay? That was a big problem.
So people tried to fix it up by
doing different models of eater,
but none of which worked.
And nobody knew why light is
behaving in this peculiar fashion.
So that's when Einstein came and said,
I know way light is behaving
in this peculiar fashion,
behaving in this way,
because if it didn't behave in this way,
the speed of light dependent
on how fast they're moving,
then when I wake up in the strain,
all I have to do is measure the
speed of light you've originally,
I got some number and I
may get a different number.
The difference will give
me the speed of the train.
So it would have been possible detective
velocity of the train without looking
outside just by doing an
experiment with light.
So even though mechanical laws involving
ethical may or the same loss of
electricity and magnetism would be
such that somehow they will betray your
velocity.
So that would mean uniform velocity does
make an observable change because it
changes the velocity of light that
you would measure. But conversely,
the fact that you keep getting the same
answer means that electric and magnetic
phenomena are part of the
conspiracy to hide your velocity.
Just like mechanical phenomenon won't
tell you how fast you're moving,
neither will electromagnetic phenomena.
Because I understand it was very obvious
that narrative will not design a system
in which mechanical laws are the same,
but lots of electricity are different.
So he postulated that all phenomenon,
whatever it be,
that nature would be unaffected by going
through a frame at a constant velocity.
I lived through the initial one.
That's a very brave postulate because
it even applies to biological phenomenon
boat, which I'm sure Ryan
stay in new video little,
but he believes that natural phenomenon,
we'll just follow either the
principal or relativity or they want.
And that is something,
uh,
something you should think about because
that puts the only reason he had.
He just said,
I don't believe chapters one through 10
and our book will be able to Nativity
and chapters 20 through 30 bed.
We do ENM, doesn't beliefs,
all of that to the phenomenon
will obey the same principle,
which says all observers or
uniform motion, that equivalent.
Now that's really based on a lot of faith.
And even though you know scientists,
generally you're a pollster
intelligent design,
we all have some bias about the
way not to. The laws were designed.
There is no question about it.
You can talk to any practicing physicists.
We have a faith that underlying loss of
nature will have a certain elegance and
a certain beauty in a certain uniformity
across all of natural phenomena.
That is a fate we have. It's, it's
not, it's not a religious issue,
otherwise I won't bring
it up in the classroom,
but it's certainly credo of all
scientists or at least all physicists,
that that is some elegance in the laws
of nature and we put a lot of money on
that fate that the laws of nature
will do this, that will not do this.
Who are we to say that?
We would wait to say a nature wouldn't
have a system in which mechanics are the
a but electricity. Magnetism doesn't, we
haven't run into somebody called nature.
We don't worship a certain
age deity called nature,
but we believe the loss
of native obey that.
So even though a scientists or physicists
in particular men are believing
designed by any personal God,
they do believe in this
underlying rational system
that we're trying to uncover.
You could be disproven, you could be
wrong and make the assumption, but he had,
it was right.
It was really driven by this notion
that all laws of physics should obey the
same principle of relativity.
So the Einsteins postulates are that
light behaves in this way because if it
didn't behave in this way, it would
violate the principle of relativity.
Whereas we know mechanical phenomena do
electrical phenomenon.
I would not, that cannot be the
case. You have a question? Yes.
Why would that apply?
Yes. Uh, because in the case
of speed of sound, you are,
you can't take the medium with you.
So that is no such experiments.
You can perform seeing the train.
If you could carry the ether with you,
it's no surprise you get the same answer.
But we know we cannot carry the medium
with us that come from steris real
experiments.
That's where the velocity of sound is
not elevated to a fundamental velocity on
which everybody will agree.
So the two great postulates,
so you've got nowhere to postulates
came from. The postulate.
Number one is simply a restatement
of the relatively principle.
I'll just say it in one sentence.
Uh,
exact wording is not
the important of inner.
She'll observers are equivalent.
Yeah.
Bye.
Equivalent means each one of them is as
privileged as any other one to discover
the loss of nature.
So the loss of nature we found are not
an accident related to our state of
motion. If I find some loss and
you're moving to the tip to me,
you will find the same laws and if you
and I find each other and relate to
motion,
you have as much right to
claim your address and I'm
moving and I have a Smith's
ready to claim that I am
addressed in your movie.
That is complete symmetry between
observers in uniform, relative motion.
There's no symmetry between people
in non uniform motion. As I said,
non uniform motion creates effects which
can destroy me and not destroy you.
So no one's trying to talk
your way out of acceleration.
Where do you can talk your
way out of uniform velocity?
That's the first principle.
So this dead even from the time of Newton.
What is true here is that all inertia
observers equivalent with respect to all
natural phenomenon,
meaning all natural laws.
Okay.
And that does a generalization.
When we say all instead of just mechanical
and the second postulate,
you call it a postulate because
there just nobody to reduce this,
which is that the velocity of light
is independent of
the state of motion
off the source of the
observer of everything.
Yeah.
If a light beam,
they admitted it the way moving rocket
doesn't matter if the light beam is seen
in a moving rocket,
doesn't matter.
All people will get the same answer
for the velocity of light. Yep.
No, that's where it's a apostolic.
You can show a few things later on.
You can show that if there is any other
speed, which is the same for everybody,
that would have to be the speed of light
in the final theory of relativity that
are not two or three velocities that
come out the same for everybody.
There's only one velocity that can
have the same answer for all people.
That velocity is the velocity of light,
but that I don't mean it has to
be light itself. For example,
gravitational waves travel at the speed
of light. It's not just the light.
It has to do the velocity of
light being a single number,
which has to have the same
value for everybody. Okay,
so it looks like he assaulted a big
problem because he has said white light
behaves this way.
Light behaves this way because it's part
of the big conspiracy to hide uniform
motion,
but you will see that you have
made a terrible bargain now
because once you take
these two postulates,
you have restored the relatively
principle to all phenomena. Okay?
You've gone beyond mechanical
phenomena to electromagnetic phenomena,
but you will find that you have to give
up all the other cherish Nordstrom's of
Newtonian physics.
Think about why we're saying here's a
car going 200 miles an hour according to
me. You get into your own car and
follow that car at 50 miles an hour,
you should get one 50 when you keep
getting 200 at places may not be true for
cars going at the speeds.
I mentioned,
but it finally you're talking
about a pulse of light.
That is true and you've got to agree
that it's really not compatible with our
daily notions or with the formula
I rode down. W Equals v minus you
when you put B equal to c w has to come
out to BC and that's not property of the
Newtonian transformation.
So what we are looking for is a new rule
for connecting x and t and experiment
[inaudible]
such that when the velocities are
computed and I played with the velocity of
light, you get the same answer.
That's what we want to do now.
So he had a sound good. I'm going to
do this now. Let's think about it.
Let me send a pumps to
the right or speech. See,
you are going to the
right at three fourth of,
see my Newtonian expectation you should
get the speed of the pulse would be one
fourth of c or do you insist that the sea,
so what will I say to you?
What will they accused you of doing?
I say you should get see over four and
you're getting C and you're finding
velocity by finding the distance
it travels and dividing.
By the time you're jacking up a number,
like one fourth to see itself.
So what could make you do that?
Yep.
Then you're going to measure,
then your eventual philosophy would,
you should have had a greater lens.
Yeah,
so one option,
let me repeat what he said.
I will say your meter sticks
or being somehow shorter.
When you and I were buddies
and we were in the same train,
we agreed on the meter stick,
but have you gone into the moving train?
I will say that there's something
wrong with the meter stick.
Not only something wrong specifically
I would say metal sticks. I've shrunk.
For example,
if they frank to one fourth,
their size is very clear that you will
get the velocity before times what they
expect. But there
another possibility. Yes,
your clocks may be running slow so you
let the light travel for four seconds and
he thought it was only one second.
That's where you got four times.
The answer out of could be both,
but something has to give.
And that is why it is an amazing theory.
That's where it sounds amazing to me
that somebody who is 26 years old would
simply follow the consequences of this
theory and take it wherever it takes you.
But there's at the very foundations of
space and time that you have to modify.
So even though you restored the relativity
of principle and brought it back to
the front, the price you have to
pay is to give up your notions.
That length is length and time is time.
We used to think of meters because a
meter stick and a clock is a clock.
If I have a clock that ticks on one
seconds, you take it on a train.
I expected to be taking one seconds,
but we're saying it's not,
or something has to give in length,
measurement of time, measurement or both.
And that's what we're going to find out.
So here is how you find the route.
So let us say that,
uh,
maybe I'll do it all in one
blackboard because this is the,
this the key to the whole calculation.
You remember now
if that is an event here,
you call it an x prime and I call it x.
Okay.
And according to me,
you have traveled the distance ut
so x prime equals x minus ut.
Yes.
What we used to say in the old days,
and the converse of that is x equals X.
Brian,
bless you tea.
But no,
we'll admit the fact that maybe a t
and t prime are no longer the same.
But that's not all we do.
I would say whenever you give me a
length x prime, I just don't buy it.
I take any length you give me.
Yeah.
And I jack it up by a factor of gamma
to get the length according to me,
the coordinator according to me,
and you will take any answer they give
you and you were multiplied by the same
factor. In other words, we
don't buy our units of length.
So if you say it should be
explained plus you tip frame, right?
That's your formula backwards for me.
Coordinate an event according to you in
the old days was explain plus Uti. No,
we admit the t and t prime and
I'd be the same. Let me say,
but I will not take your legs.
I will multiply them by Gamma to get
the lengths according to me and you will
not take my expectations, but you wouldn't
like to play it by the same gamma.
That is the symmetry between the
two observers. In other words,
if I think your meter sticks are sharp
and gamma is some number less than one,
I'm allowing you to accuse me of
having meters six, which are short.
Just very interesting.
If I said you are made of six a
short and you say my middle six,
a longer than average,
that's an absolute difference.
But we bought accuse each other of using
shotgun meter sticks and so we use the
same factor of gamma.
You're going to find this gamma now?
Yes.
Um, how do you know that?
Both the incentive time,
we'll give it the possibility.
They are different,
then we will see that they are different.
We know something's wrong with
space and something wrong with time.
So we not assume that
d prime equals the tea.
You have to open up the possibility if
you in the end it may be the nature will
say the premise tea and something
happens to link the loan,
but we will find the
answer is more symmetric.
Yep. And why do we up that?
Because that is the symmetry between
the two observers. Uh,
if, if I want to save,
you want me to stick?
So shard,
why should you can see that you should
be able to accuse me of saying the only
different between you and me as you are
moving to the right and I'm moving to
the left.
Other than the sign of the velocity,
each person says the
other person's moving.
And so we will say that any length you
give, I'll discount by a factor of gamma,
by symmetry. Anything that
I call a lengthy, we'll
discount by the same factor.
Gamble.
Now let's apply this XT
was a certain event, right?
Let's apply it to the following event.
You've got to follow this very carefully.
When you and I crossed,
remember that was at the
origin of coordinates x
equal the t equals zero and x
prime equal to p prime equal to zero.
At that instance when our origin
story to let us emit a flash of light,
okay, maybe the audit and
starts, there's a spark,
the light signal goes out and
the light signal is detected here
by a light detector.
That second event detection of the pulse,
it has a coordinate x t for me.
It has a coordinate x
prime t prime for you.
Same event as given different coordinates.
We are already used to the fact
that coordinates will be different,
but we are saying not only will
explain not be equal x t prime men,
I'd equal to t either.
Okay. But now let's write
down one important condition.
What is the relation between x prime and
deep frame in this particular pair of
events?
But what does x prime is the location
of the light poles after certain time.
So what the relation of the location of
the detection of the light poles in the
time t prime.
Yep.
Yeah,
he's saying x prime.
you guys understand that.
You agree with that statement.
This is not a random event. The second
event was the detection of a light poles.
Light Poles left the origin deep prime
seconds earlier and it's come to this
point according to this guy and the
ratio of the distance at the time is the
velocity of light but it's also true
that for me the light went to distance
accident at time t
so that's the relation
of extra tea for me. Also
I'm going to use those students,
ELLs and combine into with this defined
this factor of gamma and we will do that
now.
So I want you to multiply the lefthand
side where the left hand side and the
right hand side by the right
hand side of that equation.
I hope you understand that in the
Galilean days, in the old days,
let's see what you will say.
I will say experiments x minus ut because
the origins of shifted when a moral
duty and you will say x is explain
plus ut with the same time.
Now I'm saying time is different.
Not only that,
I don't buy your leg if you expect
me to have this length. I say no,
you exaggerated everything. I'll
scale it down by gamma and vice versa.
So if you multiply the lefthand side,
but the left hand side, you get xx prime,
the right hand side,
you get gamma square times x,
x prime plus you x deep
frying minus u x prime,
t minus used square t t prime,
no divide everything by xx prime.
Then you get one equals gamma
square times one plus you.
If you divide this by xx prime it,
we'll get deep prime over x prime.
If you divide this back six prime,
you would get tea over x.
Then you hear it,
you get used square times t o at
x five steep prime at x price.
So what does that mean?
Well t prime over x prime is one over c
and t o what? X is also one overs
because of what I wrote here.
If you want,
let me write this,
a steep frame over the next prime equal
to c and t over x equal to c so they
will,
they will cancel
and I will get one equals
gamma squared times one minus.
I use square oversee square
because this to you or what?
X is a one over CNT prime over explain.
It's another one overseas,
so that gives us the result that gamma
is one over square root of one minus
two squared or c square.
If you plug that gamma back in,
you will find x prime is
x minus ut divided by one
minus used quit or c squared.
Now once you do that, once you got
the relations with an experiment,
next you can go to the lower the
equation to solve for t frames.
I don't feel like doing that.
It's a simple algebraic equation.
Once you got to explain
how to solve for t frame,
take the second of the two
equations and solve for deep prime.
That detail I won't fill
out what you would get.
Keep prime is t minus two x
overseas squared divided by this.
So I have not done every step, but I've
given you all the things you need to do.
The one step,
I mean there are equations up there that
relate excellent experience with t and
deep prime. So if you can get experiment
terms of x and t, the other equation,
if you're solid, it will give
you t prime in terms of x and T.
And this is the results.
Okay?
This guy deserves a tool boxes because
it is the greatest results from
relativity.
It's called the Lawrence transformation.
And we're being able to derive
the load them, the summation
with what little we know.
And you can see,
you can be a kid in high
school and you can do this.
There is no calculus or anything else
involved other than being open to the fact
that velocity of light
behaves in a strange way.
Yes.
Why is steel would actually
equal to c? Oh, of course. Uh,
you quite right. So you caught
the mistake here. T or what?
X is one oversea and one oversea.
So I really meant to write x equals CT,
yes,
negative solution rejected?
No.
If you defined gamma to be the absolute
value by which you transfer lengths from
you to me, then you can take
the positive group. Well,
I can also tell you other reasons.
Uh, let's take this formula here.
Let's take the case for the velocities.
Very small competitor velocity of light
that you oversee is a very small number.
This number is almost one and I get
explained, we could explain as UTI,
which in order to be the correct
answer at low velocities,
if you pick the minus sign, I'll get
to experiment with minus x minus ut.
That's not the right answer.
Not even close to advance.
Our low velocities,
if you go to velocity,
you oversee much less than one.
You got to get back the
Galilean transformation.
You can see if you oversee goes to zero.
You can forget all about this factory
here. You can explain this x, miners,
ut and here you oversee can be neglected.
Forget all that you get p prime equals t.
So this coordinate transformation will
reduce to the Galilean transformation.
If the velocity between me and you is
much smaller than the velocity of lake.
So the formula it really
kicks in for velocity is
comparable with over last year.
Yep. Good sprayer. That speed.
Well, you start getting crazy
answers right, so you don't,
you can already see that the theory will
not admit velocities bigger than the
velocity of light.
You can already see it in this formula
that tells you that the one single
velocity that you wanted it to be.
Same for everybody.
It's honestly the greatest possible
velocity that no observer can move at the
speed with respect.
Another observer that is equal to what?
An excess of the speed of light.
So the speed of light,
which came out to be a constant in the
beginning of the theory is also turning
out to be the upper limit
on possible velocities.
That's the auditing of the statement
that no observer can travel at the speed
because in the light,
but we'll discuss it more and more.
But you have to understand what
it is that has been derived. No.
What is the meaning of this formula here?
What is it telling you?
If I say, okay, these are called
the load and transformations,
what did they tell you?
What is,
what are these numbers and
what is the significance
you like to try?
Yes.
Yeah. Well, one thing that they tell you,
it happens to be greater than
no, no, I don't mean the, what happens
in the formula and special cases?
What is it relating? What is XD
and what is extreme tip, right?
Okay.
So x prize is would be the distance that
the person who's traveling or the high
he experiences you as the speed at
which we have a person whose job,
the speed of light. Then for that
frozen distances will seem shorter.
Uh, no, I don't even want, no, see,
I'm not even telling you to get
the consequences of the equation.
What are the numbers? X and t in this
equation and what are the numbers?
[inaudible] piece frame in the sequence.
That's all
excellent.
T are
distance and time for a person
who is in right now and x,
y and to prime our distance and
time for the person who is moving.
Right.
And when you say distance and time,
what do you mean distance in time?
The way that uh,
the length of the distance will
seem to them that they travel.
Uh, but what is happening at XD?
It's the coordinates of what?
Of their location.
They are located at zero, zero, right.
What's happening at [inaudible]? Yes,
yes.
Is the event.
The key I was looking for is an event.
So here is you've got to understand what
the formula is connecting things that
happening in space and in time,
right.
Something happens here that something
has spatial coordinate at a time code in
it.
According to two observers,
the observers originally had their origins
in their clocks going site when they
passed. That's how they related and
one is moving to the rate of speed. You
then the claim is that if one event
had occurred in that accident t for one
person, for the other person moving to
the right or speed you the same event,
we'll have coordinators experiment type
frame and the relation between x and P
and experiment t frame is this?
Yep.
No. The fact that an event
has different coordinates,
it doesn't mean that'd be Aruba observing
different laws. For example, uh,
let's take a that fire extinguisher,
we look at it,
it's obeying f equals Amy,
right.
The coordinator of the fire extinguisher
with me as the audit in is quite
different from us.
The auditing.
Yeah.
You mean in this new
equations? Yeah. Yeah.
The new equations f equals
I may will not work.
That's correct.
Yes.
So the point is the loss of Newton
themselves have to be modified.
F equals I'm able to be
modified in a certain way,
but the new modified laws will reduce
the f equals m a low velocities,
which is why in the old days
it looked like f equaled Emmy,
but that'll be new laws,
but they will also have the
property that when I measured them,
I'll get the laws that will agree
with what you measured. Yes.
This individual valleys for time or
distance don't have to read the laws that
the coordinates of an event will
differ from person to person.
That's not the same as seeing the laws
as did use. Would it be different?
For example that are two stars.
We had attracted each other by gravitation
and they're orbiting around a common
center of mass.
If I see them,
I would find they obey the
law of gravitation with m
one m two overarch square
where artists,
the distance between the points and the
acceleration is whatever I think it is.
You can go on a rocket and
look at the same two stars.
They will be in a more complicated motion.
Maybe the whole system a bit
drifting dilutive to you,
but the acceleration will be the same
as what I get in the force between them.
We'll also be the same as what I get
and the laws that you will that use by
looking at that star with the
same laws that I really did use.
So that's the difference between the
laws being the and the coordinators being
the same. No one said x prime
and same in that equation there.
They are different.
We are looking at it from different
vantage point for the second did of that.
The fact that forces equal to mass times
acceleration is the same for the two
people. Okay. The last will be the same,
but things won't look the same. For
example, you can stand on your head,
don't even have to go to another frame
of reference. You stand on your head,
your z coordinates.
The minus of my CSI coordinator for
whatever event I give a z will give minus
dizzy.
But the world,
even though you're a little messed
up and want to stand on your head,
you had every right to do that because
you will find ethicals. I May. Uh,
so the point is the way we see events
may depend on what the original
coordinates,
but the loss we did use have to be
distinguished from the perception that we
have. Okay? For example,
if I'm on the ground,
I send a piece of chocolate,
goes up and goes down.
If you see me from a moving train,
you will think it went on a parabola.
So no one says the chalk will go up and
down for you, for you to go like this.
But it's motion. We'll still obey
f equals may. It's what I'm saying.
So that's all you really mean
by saying things look the same.
So what you have to understand is the
Lord and transformations are the way to
relate a pair of events and given event.
So here's a simple example.
If you live in the x, y plane, that's
a point here. It's not an event.
It's simply a point in the x,
y plane.
You measured it this way and that
way and you call it the coordinators.
If somebody else picks a different
coordinate system at an angle data,
that person will say that's x
prime and that is white frame
and x prime and white pray but
not the same. I remind the x,
prime is Xcor sine theta minus y
plus wasteland data, et cetera.
And white frame is something else. Data
is the angle between the tubes servers.
So the point is the point, it certainly
looks different than the two people,
but the same point as to coordinates.
Similarly the same event,
like the collision of two cars will have
different events for different people.
It's not,
that's not the new part.
The new part is that the
rules for connecting exterior
extremity prime is quite
different from the Galilean moons.
New rules.
It's what do you guys have to understand?
And finally,
why did Einstein get the credit for
turning the world in the fourth dimension
instead of three?
I've trawled accent ever present there
to the point is t prime is always equal
to t no matter how you move,
whether it's in the Einstein theory,
x and t gets scrambled into experiment.
T prime just the way x and y.
It gets scrambled in each other.
When you rotate your axes.
So to have time as another variable,
that doesn't transform at all.
It's not same as making
it into coordinate.
The four dimensional well of Einstein is
four dimensional because space and time
mixed with each other.
When you change your frame of reference,
that's what makes tea.
Now we coordinate that previously leaders,
something same for all people.